[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue sur tv fil
78 pour une nouvelle édition du 7 8
sociétés
le débat de ce soir faut-il interdire le
port des signes religieux à l'université
au nom de la laïcité au nom de la
laïcité est ce que le terme de laïcité
bien compris par la population
pourquoi l'université n'a pas le même
statut que les écoles primaires les
collèges ou les lycées publics y at il
une instrumentalisation politique du
terme laïcité
pourquoi le débat sur la laïcité tourne
souvent autour de l'islam vous pouvez
réagir participer posez toutes vos
questions à nos invités via les réseaux
sociaux twitter d'abord hashtag 7,8
société ou sur le facebook en tapant tv
fil 78
on attend vos commentaires on va
commencer cette émission avec une petite
définition la définition du terme
laïcité
je cite le larousse conception et
organisations de la société fondée sur
la séparation de l'église et de l'état
et qui exclut des églises de l'exercice
de tout pouvoir politique ou
administratif et en particulier de
l'organisation de l'enseignement le
principe de laïcité de l'état je le
rappelle est posée par l'article 1er de
la constitution française de 1958 dont
définition larousse alors c'est une
question d'actualité en france tout le
monde a un avis l'observatoire de la
laïcité les députés les membres du
gouvernement et ça a bien sûr des
répercussions sur notre territoire
deux syndicats d'étudiants qui se sont
exprimés sur la question on y reviendra
au cours du débat nos invités
on va commencer avec flora à sabbatique
et référente ump à l'université de
versailles saint-quentin-en-yvelines les
responsables du syndicat étudiant uni m
pour smart flora nice est allé à la cub
secrétaire général de l'unef donc pour
l'université de versailles
saint-quentin-en-yvelines également pour
son seigneur geron crop pardon
professeur agrégé d'histoire-géographie
au lycée et docteur en histoire
contemporaine spécialistes de l'école
sous la troisième république et des
questions
longuet à la laïcité pour soir gérance
robe et enfin rachid benzin qui est
islamologue philosophe à l'institut
d'études politiques d'aix-en-provence
chercheur associé à un observateur du
religieux du même institut
entre autres un vous intervenez
également dans plusieurs instituts aura
pas tous les citer
et surtout vous êtes saint quentinois
bonsoir rachid buntin bonsoir alors
depuis mars 2004
l'article l 141 1-5-1 du code de
l'éducation nous dit la chose suivante
dans les écoles les collèges et les
lycées publics le port de signes ou
tenues par lesquels les élèves
manifestent ostensiblement une
appartenance religieuse est interdite
le règlement intérieur rappelle que la
mise en oeuvre d'une procédure
disciplinaire est précédé d un dialogue
avec l'élève justement jérôme crop pour
commencer et partir d'un constat assez
simple aujourd'hui le port des signes
religieux est autorisé dans les
universités françaises
pourriez vous nous expliquer cette
spécificité de l'université française
par rapport aux écoles primaire au
collège et au lycée public pour cette
spécificité elle trouve probablement son
origine dans le fait que l'université
est un espace de débat intellectuel
ouvert à une tradition d'ouverture
intellectuelle d'ouverture sur le monde
et en plus s'adresse à des étudiants et
des étudiantes qui sont un majeur et ont
terminé leur scolarité obligatoire
donc la question de ce coin du vin se
pose un peu différemment des collèges
lycée où les élèves sont encore des
adolescents et poursuivre leur scolarité
obligatoire au moins jusqu'à 16 ans donc
historiquement en fait le débat sur la
laïcité il s'est posé à la fin la fin du
xixème siècle sous la troisième
république il s'agissait à ce moment-là
de laïciser de l'enseignement il
s'agissait de séparer en gros l'école
publique de l'église d'où les lois
scolaires du début des années 1980 en
particulier la loi de 1881 2 qui l'aï 6
l'enseignement primaire public donc pour
durée de la scolarité obligatoire des
élèves or à ce moment là donc il
s'agissait donc de séparer strictement
ce qui relevait des connaissances qui
devaient être transmises par l'école et
les croyances religieuses
il s'agissait principalement de
soustraire l'école publique à l'
influence de l'église catholique qui
assurait encore une partie du service
public d'enseignement
à travers des congrégations enseignante
notamment et n'était pas question encore
de l'université ou en tout cas d'élargir
cette laïcité à l'université non même si
par exemple l'état le monopole de la
collation des grades faire des diplômes
ce qui implique évidemment d'en
maîtriser le contenu qui est laïc
fleurance à bas que vous avez consignes
et vous avez cosigné par dans une
tribune sur le site internet huffington
post fin février pour interdire le port
du voile à l'université au nom de la
laïcité
avec ce titre je vous cite voile à
l'université réaffirmons la laïcité donc
selon vous la loi de 2004 devrait
s'étendre aux universités pourquoi alors
j'ai signé effectivement cette tribune à
titre personnel ce qui n'engage que moi
bien évidemment et pas l'intégralité du
mouvement auquel j'appartiens
j'ai signé cette tribune car j'estime
qu'il ya une réflexion à voir autour de
l'encadrement
du principe du port du voile à
l'université l'université est un service
public qui doit être protégé de toute
influence religieuse pour ça nous avons
deux solutions une solution juridique
avec une extension de la loi de 2004
dont qui interdit le port de signes
religieux dans les écoles dans
l'enseignement secondaire l'étendre à
l'enseignement supérieur
la proposition de loi déposée par eric
ciotti dans ce sens aurait une double
vertu d'une part et affirmer la place
centrale la laïcité dans le
fonctionnement de nos institutions
françaises au premier rang desquels les
universités et d'autre part mettre fin
au libre arbitre des présidents
d'université en matière de laïcité qui
crée des situations disparates et très
près égales on a une deuxième solution
qui était une solution je dirais un peu
plus social faire renaître l'homo
république à nice chez chacune et chacun
d'entre nous et je vais vous prendre à
titre d'exemple au liban les femmes de
confession vous êtes originaire 12
si j'ai bien compris les cons les femmes
de confession musulmane des saoudiennes
principalement enlève naturellement leur
voile il n'y a pas de loi sur la laïcité
au liban mais par respect elle enlève le
voile voilà alors à nous de voir
laquelle de ces deux solutions et la
plus opportune
donc on ne peut pas être si je
compromets ce que vous dites dans la
république si on porte un voile au sein
de l'université
vous abordez ce que je dis c'est quelle
est la cohérence d'une république qui
interdit le voile à l'école au collège
au lycée dans les prépas dans certains
iut mais qui l'autorisent à l'université
la laïcité ne s'arrête pas aux portes de
l'université
il ne faut pas avoir une vision
restreint de la laïcité et il faut
mettre de la cohérence dans ce système
qui n'en a plus aucun donc pour vous là
je n'ai pas une excuse
quand on sort un peu unique l'argument
de la jolie leçon majeure comment les
vacciner comment vous expliquez que les
étudiants préparent dans les lycées
n'ont pas le droit de porter le voile
mais que des étudiants majeurs toujours
dans les universités en droit l'âge est
un faux débat les à la cub le président
de l'unef williams martinez a répondu
sur médiapart à cette interdiction du
port des signes religieux en affirmant
je cite les s'est nouée
jy ensemble pour lui la proposition de
loi d'eric ciotti n'est pas laïque je le
cite toujours elle est islamophobe et
raciste
son seul objectif est de stigmatiser les
étudiantes qui porte le voile
vous partagez ce constat ben oui tout
d'abord parce que quand on me parle de
laïcité à ce moment là on remonte
jusqu'à la loi qu'il posait la
séparation de l'église et de l'état
si on part de ce principe là je vois pas
pourquoi
typiquement en alsace moselle on aurait
toujours c'est cette base du concordat
pourquoi il y aurait des enseignants de
l'enseignement catholique à liliane
qatofin voilà et donc à partir de là on
voit bien que cette loi allait diriger
spécifiquement contre une religion et
non pas la laïcité dans son dans son
ensemble et donc là typiquement c'est la
religion musulmane qui est qui et qui
visait donc à partir de à partir de là
on voit très bien que c'est pas le grand
principe républicain de la laïcité mais
que ne faut pas faire de ce principe
pauline principes politiques dans cette
voie mais bien quelque chose qui vise
uniquement les communes font uniquement
islam alors la polémique a été relancée
par une personne de votre camp si je
puis m'exprimer ainsi
puisqu'en mars dernier la secrétaire
d'état aux droits des femmes pascale
boitard a déclaré n'être je la cite pas
sûr que le voile fasse partie de
l'enseignement supérieur et c'est plutôt
prononcé dont contre le voile à
l'université rejoignant plutôt les
positions de flora sa bague
alors en fait
si je vois ce que enfin je suis d'accord
avec le fait que le le principe que la
femme enlève son voile d'elle-même et
bien des fins est préférable de tout
dans tous les cas on peut pas on peut
pas se revendiquer de valeurs féministes
ou de défense des droits des femmes
quand on quand on veut imposer une tenue
correcte tout le monde aux femmes le
canton dit que justement l'université
c'est l'université c'est un choix on a
fini le cursus obligatoire mais à
l'université c'est un choix lelong levé
le porter le voile est levé
doit on remettra aussi rachid benzine la
loi de 2004 mars 2004 pour être précis
le 15 mars interdisait le port de signes
religieux est ce qu elle devrait
s'étendre aux unités aux universités
françaises pour vous mais je pense déjà
qu' un problème de définition de ce
qu'on entend par la laïcité et dans sa
pratique notamment au niveau du
politique
je pense que le principe de laïcité
repose sur trois fondements et
l'histoire nous le montre tout d'abord
c'est la séparation entre le religieux
et le politique la liberté de conscience
est un élément constitution juridique de
l'organisation du culte dans l'espace
public or aujourd'hui avec l'objet islam
est en train de se jouer
un certain nombre de crispation qui
passent par cet aspect de l'islam et
ensuite au niveau généré à l'université
nous avons des gens qui sont notamment
libre et des défis qui sont libres de le
porter ou de ne pas le porter je pense
que la règle devrait être est ce que la
pratique du voile gêne en cours c'est ça
la grande définition
maintenant si la pratique ne gêne pas
effectivement je vois pas pourquoi il ya
cette extension de ce principe de la
laïcité on a envie de le mettre à peu
près partout ce que je veux dire c'est
que c'est à l'état d'être laïc
nous n'avons pas demandé aux usagers
d'être laïc ça je crois que c'est
quelque chose qui sinon on est dans
l'idéologie et à chaque fois que la
réussite et n'est plus ce principe
juridique elle se transforme mon
idéologie
maintenant on nous parle de valeurs
laïques de mahler djiré de morale de
morale laïque et là il ya une espèce
d'extension ce qui fait qu'on m'ait ans
je dirais en danger la laïcité elle même
et quand on voit ce qui se passe au
niveau de l'europe sur cette question là
nous sommes vraiment à part donc c'est
pour ça qu'on ne devons pas avoir
simplement ce débat d'un point du propre
français mais même de ce qui se passe au
niveau
de l'espace européen et je veux je pense
que cette question de la laïcité elle
relève d'abord d'une crise identitaire
qui très important dans la société
française où la laïcité n'est plus ce
principe juridique mais ça devient
principe identitaire on a des éléments
je dirais anti-religieux jacobins et on
a envie de d'éradiquer complètement même
dans l'espace public les signes visibles
et là je trouve que c'est quelque chose
qui est dangereux parce que confiné le
religieux dans l'espace public c'est ne
plus le confronter dans l'espace public
or nous sommes quand même dans une
société qui se veut laïc où le principe
notamment de raison est très important
pour la confrontation des débats décès
remettre le débat
alors avant que flora répondre on va
d'abord aller demander l'avis des
étudiantes et des étudiants de
l'université de versailles saint quentin
avec la question du jour que pensez-vous
des signes religieux à l'université mais
nous sommes allés poser la question aux
étudiants donc de l'université aux
abords du bâtiment
on écoute je pense que chacun fait ce
qu'il veut donc si souvent lui mettre
une croix ou comme ce soir et chacun
sait ce qui fait quoi
chacun est dans son droit de pouvoir
montrer de pouvoir - désirent porter des
signes religieux qui atteste de la
bonne foi sens de la volonté de suivre
la religion je considère qu'on est on
est libre de pouvoir porter ce qu'on
veut à la fac en fait pour moi la
laïcité c'est ça justement ces pouvoirs
ben appliquée chacun sa religion de sa
façon pas trop peur
pourquoi parce que je pense que c'est
bien de garder ça pour soi non ça peut
créer plus d dans son coach choses
parfois alors pour moi c'est pas un
problème en fait
enfin je pense que chacun est libre de
dire la religion qui veut exprimer
voilà donc propos recueillis par william
elle donc falloir à sa vague
la parole est à vous vouliez réel réagir
à ce qu'a dit notamment rachid benzine
je voulais rebondir aux avait dit quand
ça ne gêne pas effectivement la liberté
religieuse n'est pas absolue elle
s'exerce dans des conditions qui ne
portent pas atteint pour pas préjudice
aux activités d'enseignement et de
recherche
et quand vous avez un professeur en
février dernier à villetaneuse qui a été
démis de ses fonctions parce qu'il ne
souhaitait pas faire cours devant des
étudiantes voilées on peut se demander
légitimement si ces femmes voilées n'ont
pas porté atteinte à ses activités
d'enseignement et donc je pense que
c'est vraiment une question légitime et
nous devons penser à encadrer à à
discuter mais il faut que nous ayons une
solution j'en profite pour vous dire
justement est-ce que c'est légitime
qu'un professeur si ce n'est pas avant
la loi puisse ne pas vouloir faire court
parce qu'il estime que les femmes
voilées
le gène roule sont contre le principe de
la laïcité
un professeur notamment à l'université
il est là pour donner un cours et
notamment pour permettre aux étudiants
d'avoir accès à des problématiques qui
sont beaucoup plus larges et je pense
qu'à partir du moment où un
je sais pas ce qui c'est passé dans le
cas de ce professeur mais ne pas vouloir
faire court simplement devant des défis
voile et je trouve que cela ne rehausse
pas d'enseignement français et lorient
l'enseignement français
il se construit dans l'attitude critique
et même si on a des filles qui sont
voilées notamment moi je connais un
certain nombre de gérer deux professeurs
d'histoire d'islamologie qui sont
confrontés il faut qu'il y ait un vrai
débat public qui font qu'une
confrontation des idées mais on peut pas
au nom d'un principe absolu de la
évasées ou là où la laïcité devient
quelque part un ace un absolu hors sol
je dirais décidé que on ne peut plus
faire court je crois que ça n'honore pas
l'enseignement français des principes
qui sont censé justement s'applique à
certains services publics mais ses
administrateurs mais je vais agir
usagère comme on disait tout à l'heure
fonds ont le droit de porter le voile et
donc c'est un professeur la parade je ne
peux pas refuser de faire son cours
comme ça c'est là pour le coup c'est là
pour le coup c'est ébranlé le principe
de laïcité
est ce que c'est le foulard islamique
est clairement visée puisque par exemple
flora sa bague sur cette tribune qui a
été publié c'est ce ne sont pas les
signes religieux à l'université c'est
clairement le voile à l'université
pourquoi est-ce que je crois du voile
particulièrement et pas les signes
religieux en général parce que c'est
seulement le foulard islamique qui pose
problème c'est celui qu'a premier abord
quand on dit signes ostentatoires
d'appartenance religieuse on pense
directement aux voiles parce que
justement elle les problèmes étaient
malheureusement avec le voile pas avec
des croix avec des petits des petits
pots d'un pendentif
je pense qu'il faut ne pas oublier le
malaise croissant qu'un nombre de
professeurs éprouve devant des
étudiantes arborant ostensiblement des
signes d'appartenance religieuse
et ça ça crée un vrai malaise et c'est
le symptôme d montée des revendications
identitaires religieux religieuses
culturelles et donc ça pose un certain
nombre de problèmes
je pense que les à l'enseignement n'est
pas lié à l'apparition dévoile notamment
l'université je pense que le malaise né
beaucoup je dirais de d'enseignement et
j'en suis à je suis professeur donc si
c'est avant tout le manque de moyens
c'est beaucoup de choses que quelques
quelques les éléments de voile ensuite
tout à l'heure vous avez parlé de l'ibo
je pense que ces jeunes hommes ont
grandi ici elles sont françaises et son
nom de la sécularisation une pratique
individuelle et parfois même contre
leurs parents qu'elle décide de faire ce
choix de porter je crois le voile et je
pense que les laissez dire et continuez
à étudier c'est le meilleur moyen de
dire est de les émanciper de participer
à cette à cette émancipation et je crois
qu'en france on est devenus de plus en
plus idéologique s'attaque à chaque fois
que nous avons un problème nous pensons
que nous allons le régler
d'un point de vue juridique simplement
nous ne faisons que déplacer la
problématique jeudi je reviens d'un
certain nombre de tirs et de deux
rencontres avec des collégiens et des
lycéens et la problématique
elle est allée là et le fait qu'on
puisse plus parler même du fait
religieux de l'histoire religieuse et
d'un certain nombre d'éléments font que
nous avons de plus en plus de collégiens
et de lycéens qui pense que ne pas vous
parler de l'islam ne pas parler même
parfois de dieudonné ne pas parler de
toutes ces problématiques on a
l'impression que c'est la théorie du
complot
et si à l'école on ne peut pas discuter
de tous ces éléments ou est ce qu'on va
pouvoir les discuter c'est pas la
mosquée ainsi encore moins dans les
familles qui porte par contraintes
familiales ou religieuse et je dirais
c'est aussi être féministe et vous
devriez partager ma vision que
d'interdire le voile dans ces lieux de
transmission du savoir honnêtement qui
donnait affranchi de tout projet bruce
lee généralement je ne connais
aujourd'hui à d'université aucune femme
qui le porte paro bligations parce que
ses parents l'obligent au contraire ceux
que je rencontre c'est beaucoup plus de
parents qui ne veulent pas que leurs
filles portent le voile alors qu'elles
ont franchement individuel voilà la
véritable revendication les arrêter moi
je suis féministe et c'est pas ça être
féministe que d'imposer une tenue
correcte ou non à une femme
on retourne vraiment dans des villes où
travers de la france que dire les femmes
ne doivent pas porter tel ou tel ou tel
ou tel vêtement justement être féministe
c'est juste pouvoir permettre la
démocratisation de l'enseignement
supérieur et pouvoir permettre l'accès à
aller d'une éducation aux femmes même
voilé et parce que c'est comme ça que
c'est juste comme ça qu'est ce qu'elles
pourront faire leur vie quoi
alors on parle beaucoup du vol alors
jérôme crop atwan assiste à une
évolution du concept de laïcité c'était
ces trente dernières années à ce qu est
ce qui a eu un élément déclencheur qui
fait qu'on est passé comme sous la
troisième république ou un peu plus tôt
dans l'histoire de la laïcité a eu notre
laïcité sur les élèves notamment
disposent de façon extrêmement
différentes
le débat en fait sur le foulard
islamique il apparaît en 1989 la fraise
de creil a vraiment avec la sphère d'un
creil bien connu qui a fait l'objet
d'une large médiatisation et qui a
entraîné une transformation du débat
c'est à dire que désormais il ne s'agit
plus de laïciser l'école donc mais de
deux d'enjoindre à des élèves eux-mêmes
de d'adopter une forme de laïcisation de
la ici de se laïciser d'un gâteau ne
d'être neutre ce qui peut se comprendre
encore une fois dans le cadre de la
scolarité obligatoire débat a été
tranché par la loi du cadenas 15 mars
2004 qui d'ailleurs n'a pas rencontré
beaucoup de difficultés à s'appliquer
pain constate que la majorité des
musulmans de france ont compris cette
fois et et l'on l'on respecté en
revanche à l'université de la question
se pose différemment et de la plupart du
temps les étudiantes qui porte ce
foulard islamique le font par choix pour
manifester notamment une identité
donc il s'agit effectivement d'une
affirmation identitaire mais qui ne
menace pas forcément l'enseignement dans
la mesure où elles adoptent une attitude
neutre vis-à-vis de l'enseignant du
contenu enseigné il m'arrivait
d'enseignés encore récemment les
l'histoire du système scolaire et des
lois de jules ferry et face à un
auditoire où se trouvaient des jeunes
filles portant le foulard
et je n'ai ressenti aucune gêne par
rapport à cela c'est à dire que au
contraire il faut qu'elles entendent ce
cette histoire qu'elle comprenne cette
histoire de la laïcité puisque laïcité
servante où le vivre ensemble et c'est
une un principe républicain qui protège
d'ailleurs historiquement les minorités
religieuses y compris les français
musulmans
j'en profite pour ajouter une question
que vous pouvez relire flora on parle de
combien de personnes on a l'impression
que c'est un phénomène peut être à cause
des médias ou à cause du temps de parole
qui consacre à cette question de cette
problématique concerne combien de
personnes si on parle de filles voilées
par exemple ce qui vient d'un 5000-10000
60000 formule alors on n'a pas un
chiffre précis
ce que je veux dire c'est surtout par
les affaires médiatiques ça remonte à ce
que je voulais rebondir comment vous
régler cette situation de rupture
d'égalité entre les femmes qui sont dans
les prépas et qui n'ont pas le droit de
porter le voile
et il ya des prépas dans les universités
où elles ont le droit bon ça crée une
situation inégalitaire
je voulais rebondir il faut encadrer
cette pratique quand vous avez en examen
des femmes qui ont des voiles elles
peuvent cacher une oreillette ne rigolez
pas ne rigolez pas je ne rigole
absolument pas vous voulez dire quel
poste de serveur du voile pour tricherie
faut encadrer cette pratique et je
voulais enfin terminée par dire qu'un
sondage nous informe que trois quarts
des français sont opposés au port du
voile à l'université 78% à nous d'en
tirer les conséquences
bon j'ai trop parlé du malaise des
professeurs tout à leur enseigner devant
les devant des étudiants de voile et
nous sommes à la même université
quant à les professeurs en l1 de droit
qui font descendre les étudiants de
voile est au premier rang pour qu'elles
pour vérifier les oreilles de leurs
voiles et pour qu'elles composent leurs
parcelles au premier rang pour être bien
surveillés quels triche pas ça s'est pas
séparé du malaise c'est pas des
stigmatisations et ça reste moi j'ai
jamais vu ça
donc ça reste tel professeur sauvage il
faut un cadre il faut réglementer
sinon chaque professeur va faire comme
il souhaite il ya quatre professeurs
très bien qu'ils vont vérifier avant le
partiel si effectivement il n'y a pas
d'oreillettes dissimulé et y en a
d'autres qui vont oublier
ils font un cadre réglementaire mais tu
te fais fouilles et été chauds
sous des cheveux ou des oreilles
généralement elles sont imprévisibles et
on peut lâcher des antisèches dans un
voile ses lectrices et paf on sait pas
si tu te fais pas ça y est on alors la
selle de cheval de troie de la triche le
voile à l'université
non mais je pense qu'on est dans des
représentations qui sont fantasmagorique
et comment des éléments gérer divers
deviennent des vérités absolues dans
l'espace public par des effets de
médiatisation et de surenchère je crois
qu'il faut regarder la réalité en face
et surtout faire preuve de bon sens et
j'ai l'impression que sur toutes ces
questions religieuses dans l'espace
public
des convois du religieux dans l'espace
public on a un animal pourquoi parce que
l'histoire de france en tout cas
l'histoire de la laïcité elle s'est
construite contre le religieux et donc
chaque fois que cette visibilité du
religieux dans l'espace public on a on a
du mal et donc du coup quelqu'un qui est
croyant quand il nous dit qu'il est
croyant on trouve ça complètement
bizarre en sort c'est à dire que
quelqu'un ça relève de l'archaïsme on se
demande si la raison ne l'a pas encore
atteint 2 par ses lumières et je crois
qu'il faut il faut faire au cas par cas
y je pense que l'université il faut pas
trop touché sur sur cette voie et il n'y
a pas de raison de ne pas nous en sortir
mais surtout on regarde on sait ce qui
se passe au niveau européen je crois
qu'on a qu'on est quand même assez isolé
sur cette question de la laïcité donc du
coup il ya il ya la laïcité devient
l'alpha et l'oméga de la société
française à partir de laquelle elle se
voit et lcl sur projet ce qui ce qui
n'est pas du tout une réalité la
convention européenne des droits de
l'homme a jugé la digne d'intérêt et la
question qui se posait en turquie sur le
port du voile à l'université
on n'est pas en turquie non je n'ai pas
les chronos mais je pense qu'il faut
arrêter de faire référence aux pays
étrangers parce que ça c'est on est dans
la construction de l'imaginaire on est
dans le choc des imaginaires je crois
qu'il faut régler le regarder la réalité
française de ce qui se passe à
l'université ici de saint quentin à
nanterre ailleurs et regarder la réalité
en face on n'a pas besoin d'aller ni au
liban et en turquie
s'il ne dit pas justement racing basé
liban et turquie parce que pour la
majorité des français
l'islam est étranger mais elle vient de
l'extérieur nous puisque lille d'abord
l'islam et tous les historiens le
montrent il ya déjà une présence dès le
moyen âge
ensuite le rapport de l'islam avec la
société française
on l'a eue pendant centre deux ans en
algérie il n'est pas lié à la présence
de ces 50 dernières années donc la
france a une longue histoire avec
l'islam et donc il faut sortir de cette
amnésie est reconvoqué là je dirais
l'histoire pour revoir ce récit national
qu'on est en train de nous raconter et
qui ont put je dirais une partie de ce
récit de sa propre histoire
la lagune conclusions rapidement puisque
l'émission se termine ben du coup et
nous je pense pas qu'on puisse au nom de
la laïcité ou au nom de valeurs
féministes féministe d'égalité femmes
hommes pour considérer qu' il faut
interdire le voile à l'université ou au
contraire justement et et pour permettre
justement à ces filles d'avoir un accès
à l'enseignement supérieur on ne peut
pas on ne peut pas vains mots j'ai
demandé à mon entourage à des filles
voilées qui passait justement dans notre
local de l'unef à à saint quentin selon
leur donnons leur a demandé est-ce que
vous concrètement si on nous interdit le
port du voile à l'université est ce que
vous continuez à venir à l'université et
elles nous ont répondu non et à partir
de à partir de ce constat là on ne peut
pas interdire interdire le port du voile
à l'université la savak un dernier mot
puis on les fera jérôme cork conclure
non relire les cons les rapports aussi
du haut conseil à l'intégration qui
préconisait effectivement un encadrement
jeu real après comme je répété il sait
pas l'encadrement ce rapport sera pas
forcément juridique et peut-être social
en faisant renaître
l'homo républicaine us chez chacune et
chacun d'entre nous et ça c'est un
combat de tous les jours me régale
vraiment en quelques secondes et encore
portable
le quelques secondes il me semble qu'il
faut insister sur le fait que la laïcité
est d'abord fondé comme ça a été dit sur
la volonté d'assurer à tous les citoyens
la liberté de conscience le droit de
pratiquer leur culte et et l'accès à une
école et un enseignement neutre du point
de vue religieux et c'est vraiment et il
faut surtout pas que ce principe de
laïcité ça me semble important de liens
en conclusion soit instrumentalisée pour
servir de cache sexe à ddd phénomène de
discrimination est en flammes merci à
tous les cas d'avoir participé à ce
débat nous nous retrouvons la semaine
prochaine à 18h30 en direct
nous parlerons du numérique dans les
écoles n'hésitez pas à vous rendre sur
le site internet de tv fils tv fil 78
points comme pour poser vos questions
merci à tous
à la semaine prochaine et bonne soirée
[Musique]